Traductor: Ester Díaz
Revisor: Elisabeth Buffard
En la historia bíblica
de la Torre de Babel
la humanidad hablaba
solo un idioma
hasta que se dividieron
en varios grupos
incapaces de entenderse
entre ellos.
No sabemos si ese
idioma original existió
pero sí sabemos que los miles
de idiomas actuales
pueden rastrearse hasta
un número mucho menor.
¿Cómo hemos acabado con tantos?
En la época histórica
de las migraciones,
el mundo estaba
mucho menos poblado.
Los grupos de personas que
compartían idioma y cultura
solían dividirse
en tribus más pequeñas,
buscando caza fresca
y tierras fértiles.
Conforme migraban y
se asentaban en otros sitios,
quedaban aislados entre ellos
y evolucionaron de formas distintas.
Tras siglos de vida diferente
con otra comida
y con vecinos distintos,
los dialectos parecidos con variaciones
en pronunciación y vocabulario
se convirtieron
en idiomas distintos
que se dividían conforme los pueblos
crecían y se expandían.
Como los genealogistas, los lingüistas
intentan crear un mapa de este proceso
rastreando varios idiomas
tan atrás como sea posible
hasta su antepasado común,
o protolengua.
Un grupo de idiomas relacionados así
se llama familia de lenguas
que tiene varias
ramas y subfamilias.
Pero primero, ¿cómo sabemos
qué idiomas se relacionan?
Los sonidos parecidos
no indican mucho.
Podrían ser falsos dobletes
o simples préstamos
en vez de tener una raíz común.
La gramática y la sintaxis
son más fiables
así como el vocabulario básico
tal como pronombres,
números o parentescos
donde hay menos
probabilidades de préstamo.
Comparando estos rasgos
y buscando patrones habituales
de cambios de sonido
y correspondencias
entre estos idiomas,
los lingüistas
establecen relaciones
y rastrean pasos concretos
en su evolución
e incluso reconstruyen idiomas anteriores
sin documentos escritos.
La lingüística puede incluso revelar
pistas históricas importantes,
tales como el origen geográfico
y el estilo de vida de pueblos antiguos
basándose en qué palabras son suyas
y cuáles son préstamos.
Los lingüistas tienen
dos problemas
al reconstruir el árbol
de los idiomas.
Uno es que no se sabe con certeza
dónde terminan las ramas
es decir, qué dialectos se consideran
idiomas separados y viceversa.
El chino se clasifica
como un solo idioma
pero sus dialectos son
ininteligibles entre sí
mientras que el español y el portugués
pueden entenderse mutuamente.
Los idiomas hablados hoy en día
no están en categorías
claramente separadas
sino que su transición es gradual,
cruzando límites y clasificaciones.
La diferencia entre idioma y dialecto
es a menudo una cuestión
política y nacional
en vez de ser un rasgo lingüístico.
Por eso la respuesta
a cuántos idiomas hay
puede ser entre 3000 y 8000
dependiendo de quién cuenta.
Además, cuanto más atrás
nos remitamos en el tiempo
hacia lo alto del árbol,
hay menos pruebas
de las lenguas allí.
La principal división
de familias de lenguas
representa el límite en que
se puede establecer las relaciones
con una certeza razonable,
por lo que supuestamente
los idiomas de diferentes familias
no se relacionan a ningún nivel.
Pero esto puede cambiar.
Aunque las relaciones
a un nivel más alto,
o superfamilias,
son especulativas,
unas han sido aceptadas
y otras están siendo consideradas,
sobre todo con idiomas
de población nativa reducida
que aún no han sido
estudiadas ampliamente.
Puede que nunca descubramos
cómo surgieron los idiomas
o si todos tienen
un antepasado común
dispersado por la Torre de Babel
de las migraciones.
Cuando oigas un idioma
extranjero, pon atención.
Podría no ser tan extranjero
como piensas.